the cdu is triumphant as they convened
today they were still in a celebratory
mood they'd been expecting victory but
the strength of the result surprised
even them
at the press conference that followed
the chancellor was lauded once again she
paid tribute to her fdp partners in
government who voters booted out of
parliament
i'd like to thank our current coalition
partners the free democrats
i'm sorry they fell short of entering
the bundestag by just 0.2
percent merkel told journalists she'd
slept soundly but admitted the long
election night had left her a little
tired
i woke up in a good mood that went hours
more sleep wouldn't have hurt
the question on everyone's lips is who
will the conservatives govern with
merkel said no discussions had been
arranged so far
of course we're open to talks i've
already made contact with the chairman
of the spd
he understandably asked us to wait until
they have their convention on friday
merkel said she had taken care not to
provide any false leads through her
choice of clothing
i stood in front of my closet this
morning and thought i can't wear red
bright greens out i wore blue yesterday
so what am i going to do
before haste is a trademark miracle
quality and one that appears to have
endeared her to the voters